que sigue entonces para Pedro Castillo
después de haber intentado disolver el
parlamento gobernar por decreto convocar
a elecciones parlamentarias y estar
ahora detenido como ya lo confirmó la
fiscalía del país
Qué tal Buenas noches bueno en términos
muy cortos es el fin político de Pedro
Castillo probablemente sea condenado o
entre un juicio en el cual él tenga no
solamente que responder a la justicia
por lo que ha sucedido el día de hoy que
es un intento de gol de autogolpe sino
también por una serie investigación que
ha tenido el ex presidente peruano en
delitos que se relacionan a la
corrupción de de hecho el presidente
había sido investigado por liderar una
organización criminal Entonces en ese
sentido creo que es el fin de un
político bastante precario que ha sido
Pedro Castillo muy criticado y muy
señalado por diferentes sectores señoras
segarra estos hechos ocurridos en Lima
en Perú el día de hoy pueden poner fin a
esta crisis política que ha vivido el
país en los últimos seis años esta
sucesión de antecedentes de
destituciones De retiros de cambios de
gobierno y de elecciones
lamentablemente no si bien había dicho
que era el fin de Pedro Castillo esto no
significa que sea el fin de la crisis
política de hecho entramos en un
escenario mucho más complicado debido a
que Dina boluarte no tiene el apoyo
parlamentario que sí tenía Pedro
Castillo que de alguna u otra manera
hacía que pudiera sobrevivir en este
caso tenemos a una nueva presidente que
si bien ha pedido el diálogo y el
trabajo en conjunto con el legislativo
creo que va a ser una tarea muy
complicada que lo logre generar en el
sentido de que existe el parlamento por
ejemplo peruano está altamente
fragmentado no solamente no responde a
partidos políticos sino en muchas
ocasiones agendas individuales eso
también se evidencia en el
comportamiento de los congresistas
puesto que las negociaciones No
necesariamente se dan a partir de grupos
legislativos sino a nivel personal
Entonces si bien Dina Volverte Podría
tener o invitar a diversos comentarios y
a sus partidos políticos a
integrarla diversos ministerios dentro
del gabinete esto no le asegura su
permanencia de hecho creo sería muy
importante que los los parlamentarios se
autorregulen y creo que que ha faltado
muchísimo desde estas crisis que hemos
tenido a partir del 2016 señora
justamente le quería preguntar por el
congreso que ha vacado al presidente un
congreso que no goza de popularidad
entre los ciudadanos peruanos sumamente
desprestigiado que sigue entonces para
esta institución después de los hechos
ocurridos hoy de haber llevado a cabo
esta vacancia del presidente
muchos parlamentarios son considerados
que esto ha sido una victoria bueno ha
sido una victoria de la Democracia no
sin duda alguna pero no es una victoria
de la institución del Congreso es
importante recordar que esta es
es un congreso altamente desconfiado o
altamente impopular por parte de los de
para las y los peruanos en muchas
ocasiones ante esta grave crisis
política la mayoría de ciudadanos según
las encuestas solicitaba que hayan
elecciones presidenciales pero también
parlamentarias ahora sí va a ser Va a
ser importante ver cuál va a ser el
nuevo comportamiento de los legisladores
en el sentido si es que van a estar
continuando tendiendo este conflicto
entre con Dina boluarte o van a entrar
en un proceso que que se ha olvidado
parece en la democracia peruana que es
que si bien los poderes se controlan
también pueden cooperar y sería muy
importante que lo hagan